in Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz is
trying to hold off Democratic challenger
Beto O'Rourke recent polls reveal a
close race with Cruz ahead immigration
issue is taking center stage in that
race the migrant caravan continues its
journey through Mexico as president
Trump sends more troops to the border
Texas shares more than 1,200 miles of
border with Mexico
Adriana Diaz is on the US side in El
Paso Adriana good morning good morning
Beto O'Rourke's hometown of El Paso sits
right on the US border and there have
been people crossing in from Mexico all
morning many of them going to work now
u.s. Border Patrol said that they plan
to conduct a crowd control exercise here
which many Democrats called an attempt
to suppress Latino vote we reached out
to US border patrol and we have not
heard back immigration of course is in
the spotlight here this Election Day
there are an estimated 1.4 million
undocumented immigrants living in Texas
and according to a CBS News battleground
tracker poll 63 percent of Texans say
illegal immigration is a big problem the
two candidates for Senate here offer
very different solutions Republican
Senator Ted Cruz says he wants to build
a border wall and he wants no legal
protections no amnesty granted to anyone
who enters the US illegally
Democratic congressman better O'Rourke's
wants a path for citizenship for
undocumented immigrants and legal
protections for dreamers and asylum
seekers now nearly 40 percent of Texans
identify as Hispanic or Latino and while
many of them are Pro immigration not all
of them are we met a Mexican American
man yesterday who says that he wants her
to be a clamp down on illegal
immigration he told us that he voted
early for Ted Cruz because Cruz has the
president support and because he thinks
Cruz in office will be better for his
small business Gael all right thank you
very much Arianna